Hello everyone and welcome to the content
video going over section
3.7 while statements.
You'll actually hear me call
them while loops instead
of while statements, but we
call them while statements
for now because they actually
act very similarly to an
if statement. So let me
kind of explain what I mean.
Let's walk through this one example
really quick and then I'll show you
what I mean. So I like this example
in the textbook with pseudocode.
So when we go shopping we make a list
of items we need to buy right and
so if we were going to write some
code or an algorithm to cross out an
item after we've bought it and move
to the next item until we run out
of items on our list we would pseudo
code that and say something like
wow there are more items on my shopping
list buy the next item and cross
it off my list so as long as there's
more items keep crossing them
off keep buying them crossing them
off okay um so what I what that looks
like when it comes to code is
actually very similar syntactically to
an if statement. And so what you can
see here in the textbook is while
product greater than or equal to 50
product equal product times three.
And what that's essentially saying,
this is actually doing something
slightly different from the
pseudocode example, but you
can see that the while statement
is looking for a statement
of true or false, just
like the if statement was,
right? If it's true or if it's
false, it will execute that.
It will enter the while loop, I
guess, and it will execute the
code underneath. Now, what makes
a while statement different than
an if statement is that the condition
in the while statement, if it
continues to return true, it will
continue to keep executing the
code underneath the statement.
So, let me show you what I mean.
Let's
make a simple uh if statement uh
let's let's check for a condition
let's get some input from the
user's time how are you today
and we'll have them enter how
they're feeling and so we'll say
while let's say they enter happy
while condition equals happy.
We'll print out something
like, wow, I'm so happy that
you are, whoops, you are
happy. Very aggressively. Okay,
now let's run this code and
see what happens. Actually,
false. Let me change one thing. Let's
change this to an F statement first.
let me run this code okay so how
are you today I am happy wow I'm
so happy that you're happy gets
output to the console right so let's
change this back to a while
statement and you can probably guess
what's going to happen already how
are you today happy and we get this
so this just continues to print we
get wow I'm so happy that you're
happy and and you can see that
it's printed like a million times
at this point and like I can't
even reach the bottom of the scroll
back anymore because I was done oh
there we go yeah so uh you can see
it's just going to keep running
so I'm actually going to um just
kill this terminal altogether because
I don't want it to keep running
um what what this condition is
called is a um oh shoot the name is
escaping me basically it's a
it's an infinite loop right it's
something that's going to continue
running unless we state some condition
for it to stop. Or we use something
called a break or a continue.
So our while loop will
continue to run unless this
condition becomes false. Let
me show you an example where a
condition might become false.
Let's say we have an age.
And let's just set it at five. And
we'll say while age less than 100.
We'll do something like grid the age.
And then let's say age
equals age plus one.
Oh, you know what? Let me
comment out this because
that will cause an
infinite loop every time.
Okay, let me make this
a little bit bigger.
So you can see on our scroll
back here that our loop
started at age equal 5 and
then age became 6, 7, etc, etc,
until age reached 99.
And we printed out age equal
99 and then age said age equals
age plus 1, so we did an
addition there to make age 100,
and then age was no longer
less than 100 so our loop
actually closed. The condition
became false and so it ended.
Now another cool thing about while
statements or while loops is that
similar to if statements we can throw
an else on the end there. Okay so
this is cool because then let's
say we hit the condition where our
age is no longer less than 100. We
can print out something like hey you
got old and we can run this again and
you can see that our age continues
to tally up from 5 to 99 and then
at the end of it the condition
becomes false and remember when an
if statement in an if statement if
you have an if and an else if the if
statement ever becomes not true or
if it isn't true then we automatically
run the else and that's exactly
what's happening here. The wild
statement becomes false and so we jump
down to our else and we print out
the else at the end of it. So wild
statements will continue to repeat
a condition as long as it's true.
And that's kind of the gist of this
content video, so thanks for watching.